تم نقلهم عبر الحشود التي احتفل بها
آلاف الفلسطينيين، هؤلاء الصبية هم
من بين 33 مراهقًا تم إطلاق سراحهم من
السجون الإسرائيلية يوم
السبت. هذه لحظة أمل بالنسبة للكثيرين هنا في
الضفة الغربية المحتلة،
وبالنسبة لأولئك الذين تم إطلاق سراحهم الآن، فهي لحظة
ارتياح تام، أنا سعيد جدًا  لا أستطيع أن أصدق أن هذا
حقيقي، يقول إبراهيم إنني لا
أعرف حتى ماذا أقول.
هذا المشهد هو نتاج
اتفاق هدنة دقيق لمدة 4 أيام بين إسرائيل وحماس
من المقرر أن يشهد
إطلاق سراح 150 سجينًا ومعتقلًا فلسطينيًا وما
لا يقل عن 50 إسرائيليًا  تم تحرير الرهائن من
أسر حماس في
غزة، هناك العديد من العائلات الفلسطينية
التي ستظل تنتظر بفارغ الصبر
معرفة ما إذا كان سيتم إطلاق
سراح أحبائها أيضًا. وقد احتشدت عائلة التميمي التي شوهدت هنا يوم
السبت منذ أشهر للمطالبة
بالإفراج عن وسام البالغ من العمر 17 عامًا
أصيب بجروح خطيرة على يد القوات الإسرائيلية
واعتقلته لاحقًا في يونيو/حزيران. اتهمته
إسرائيل بارتكاب جرائم بما في ذلك حيازة
سلاح، لكن لم يتم توجيه أي تهمة إليه مطلقًا، والآن
أصبح هو وعائلته معًا أخيرًا
[موسيقى]
مرة أخرى،
العديد من المفرج عنهم الآن هم من بين
أكثر من 3000 فلسطيني محتجزين  تحت
الاعتقال الإداري، مما يعني أنه لم يتم
توجيه أي تهم ضدهم ولا توجد
إجراءات قانونية مستمرة. وتقول إسرائيل إن
بعض المفرج عنهم كانوا محتجزين
بتهم تتعلق بالإرهاب أو الأسلحة، ولكن في
قائمة نشرتها السلطات الإسرائيلية تضم
300 امرأة وطفل مؤهلين
للإفراج عنهم ورشقوا الحجارة و
كان الإضرار بالأمن الإقليمي من بين
التهم الأكثر شيوعًا، فهناك أطفال هنا
كانوا في السجن لمدة 8 سنوات و5
سنوات و6 سنوات، وهو أمر غير مقبول، والعديد
منهم الآن يعانون من مشاكل نفسية كبيرة
بسبب التعذيب، أو على الأقل
تعذيب نفسي بسبب الطريقة التي
كانوا بها.  تم استجوابه، هل هذه هي
الفظائع الفظيعة التي تمارس
ضد هؤلاء
الأطفال من أجل الحشود المتجمعة هنا في
الضفة الغربية المحتلة، هذا الاحتفال الذي
يقولون إنه رمز
للعدالة الذي يجمع آلاف
الفلسطينيين معًا للمشاركة في
فرحة العائلات التي تم لم شملها الآن ولكن  بالنسبة
للكثيرين، فإن الفرح يقترن بالحزن
والألم الذي نشعر به بشدة هنا. بالنسبة لشعب
غزة، نحن سعداء للغاية ولكننا لا نزال
غارقين في الحزن ونشعر بحزن شديد بسبب
كل ما يحدث هنا في فلسطين
ولكن في نفس الوقت مازلنا قادرين على الاستمرار في المضي قدمًا.
كل ما يمكننا القيام به من
أجل تحقيق أملنا في تحقيق ذبابة البحار
ونأمل لاحقًا في
باش التحرير الكامل لشبكة CNN في
رالا